[Cancer Among Veterans, Early Diagnosis]
[Presented by The Administrator of Veterans'
Affairs.]
[Produced by Division of Motion Pictures,
Department of the Interior.]
[Under the direction of Veterans Administration
Exhibits Committee. Photomicrography by
L. H. Prince, M. D., Hines, Illinois. Photography
by Walter K. Scott.]
[Narrative by... Max Cutler, M. D., Consultant,
Tumor Clinic,
Veterans Administration Facility, Hines, Illinois.]
[Narrator:] Under the direction of the Administrator
of Veterans' Affairs, the Veterans Administration
is making every effort towards furnishing
ex-servicemen with the benefits of early diagnosis
and the prompt and skillful treatment of cancer.
This parent hospital at Hines, Illinois provides
more than 400 beds for tumor cases and serves
as a training ground for physicians selected
to specialize in the diagnosis and treatment
of this disease.
Leaving the beautiful and spacious grounds,
we enter the hospital where the Tumor Board
is in session and hear the voice of Dr. Max
Cutler, consultant in tumors at the Hines
facility, who will present his subject, the
early diagnosis of cancer. Dr. Cutler.
[Dr. Max Cutler:] Early diagnosis is the keystone
to cancer control. An accurate diagnosis is
the basis of correct and effective treatment.
All the progress that has been realized in
the surgical and radiation treatment of cancer
is of no avail unless the lesion is recognized
early and treated correctly before it has
become disseminated.
[Dr. Max Cutler:] Thus early diagnosis resulting
in the elimination of precancerous conditions
and in the cure of early cancer is by far
the most important single factor in the curability
of this disease.
The external cancers can be detected in their
very early stages and are both presentable
and curable. The internal cancers unfortunately
present a much more complex problem.
And although much can be accomplished by careful
attention to early diagnosis, real progress
in this group awaits the discovery of a diagnostic
test much more delicate then is now available.
We will now consider three forms of cancer
which pass through definite precancerous stages
and are, therefore, not only curable but preventable.
Cancer of the mouth, preceded by leukoplakia;
cancer of the skin preceded by hyperkeratosis;
and melanoma preceded by apparently innocent
moles.
We begin with leukoplakia, one of our most
important precancerous conditions. This lesion
is ten times as common in men as in women.
Hence, 90 percent of cancers of the mouth
occur in men.
The well known relation between tobacco and
leukoplakia has given rise to the term, "Smoker's
patch."
Here you see a leukoplakia of the mucous membrane
of the cheek in which smoking is the etiological
factor. An underlying susceptibility of the
tissues to nicotine must be present for leukoplakia
to develop.
In susceptible individuals, it is probable
that infinitesimal amounts of the stimulating
chemical agent can result in this condition.
The relationship between leukoplakia and cancer
is well-illustrated in this case, where you
see an intense radiation reaction after treatment
of a cancer of the right cheek, which developed
in a patch of leukoplakia.
Leukoplakia often occurs at the site of artificial
dentures as in this case. Here we see a diffuse
leukoplakia of the roof of the mouth in a
patient whose mucous membrane is evidently
susceptible to chronic irritation and to nicotine.
A combination of factors is usually responsible
for this type of lesion. When a patch of leukoplakia
begins to undergo malignant degeneration,
it exhibits certain clinical signs.
It becomes thickened and somewhat indurated
and its surface becomes fissured and eroded.
In this stage the lesion is either precancerous
or already fully malignant.
True ulceration almost invariably means that
carcinoma has become established. When these
clinical signs appear, a biopsy is usually
necessary to establish the diagnosis of cancer.
In this connection it should be emphasized
that a negative biopsy by no means excludes
the presence of cancer and one must be guided
largely by the clinical picture.
Dental caries is etiologically related to
cancer of the oral mucous membrane. A sharp
or broken tooth can produce repeated trauma
to the adjacent mucous membrane and results
in a traumatic ulcer and finally in carcinoma.
This is a remarkable example of this type.
Note the precise relationship between this
jagged tooth and the lesion in the mucous
membrane of the cheek. Removal of the source
of irritation results in prompt disappearance
of the ulcer when it is only inflammatory.
Leukoplakia of the oral mucous membrane frequently
arises at the site of dissimilar metal fillings
in patients who are non-smokers and in the
absence of both non-specific inflammation
and syphilis.
The development of the leukoplakia at the
exact site of the dissimilar filling as in
this case and the absence of other etiologic
factors constitute significant evidence of
this probable relationship.
The lateral border of the tongue being in
close proximity to carious and infected teeth
is a common site of leukoplakia. The dorsum
is affected more commonly when the lesion
is diffuse. Often it is on a syphilitic basis.
Extensive diffuse leukoplakia is usually associated
with syphilis. The cancers of the lip and
tongue are quite independent. Each arose in
a separate patch of leukoplakia. Such lesions
may arise simultaneously or they may be separated
by months or years.
The prognosis of cancer of the mouth associated
with syphilitic leukoplakia is extremely grave.
The modification in the connective tissue
and blood vessels resulting from the syphilitic
infection has a most unfavorable influence
upon the surgical and radiation result and
a cure is almost never accomplished in spite
of the efficiency and thoroughness of the
treatment.
In spite of the early signs they produce,
cancers of the oral cavity still reach an
advanced stage in many patients. The last
two cases are examples of this fact.
Cancer of the lower lip is overwhelmingly
a disease of men. The lesion begins as a small
localized nodularity which has to be differentiated
from a benign hyperkeratosis.
Lesions of this extent are readily curable
by surgery or by irradiation. In later stages
the disease spreads to the adjacent skin and
oral mucosa. And the lesion becomes indurated,
ulcerated and painful as in this example.
Lesions of this extent are usually accompanied
by cervical adenopathy and when the growth
approaches or crosses the midline, one must
assume that the adenopathy is bilateral, even
though this is not demonstrable clinically.
A projecting tooth, especially when it is
sharp, sometimes traumatizes the lip causing
first an ulcer than a carcinoma. This is a
clinical example. Note the precise anatomical
relation between the tooth and the carcinoma.
[ Showing lesion on lip ]
Cancer can begin in the mucous membrane of
the upper or lower lip or cheek as a small,
firm, circumscribed and movable tumor, which
grows slowly and remains non-ulcerated for
a long time.
These lesions originate in the epithelium
of ducts of mucous glands. Because they are
non-ulcerated and freely movable they resemble
simple benign mucous cysts and are invariably
so diagnosed.
They are usually removed inadequately and
recur promptly. They are often highly malignant
and unless this peculiar type of carcinoma
is diagnosed properly and treated correctly
the first time, the results are disastrous.
The
differential diagnosis of cancer of the mouth
must consider benign papillomatous lesions,
primary and tertiary syphilis, papilloma durum
of the tongue, tuberculosis and mixed tumors
of salivary glands.
Here we have two cases of tuberculosis of
the mouth. Tuberculosis of the tongue is rare.
When it occurs, it is usually associated with
an active pulmonary lesion. Tuberculous ulcerations
appears as a flat non-indurated lesion which
is painful and tender.
The ulcer lacks the surrounding infiltration
and induration which is so characteristic
of carcinoma. When the nature of the lesion
is in doubt clinically a biopsy should be
performed to establish the diagnosis with
certainty.
The aberrant salivary glands give rise to
an interesting and peculiar group of tumors.
In the mouth these tumors arise within the
cheek, the lip, the base of the tongue and
the soft palate. Salivary glands and tumors
of the soft palate may reach a large size
as seen in this case.
The small tumors are generally cured by wide
surgical removal. Inadequate excision is followed
by prompt recurrence. When these tumors reach
a large size and recur in older individuals,
the patient's comfort and life expectancy
are often benefited by a conservative course.
The chief points in the differential diagnosis
are their location, their slow growth, and
the fact that they remain circumscribed for
long periods. Unlike the carcinomas, they
remain non-ulcerated for many years in spite
of their large size.
There are three main types of skin cancer.
This is the basal cell form and it's commonly
referred to as "rodent ulcer." The next is
the squamous cell type with [inaudible] and
pearl formation.
And the third is the adenoid cystic type,
which is usually classified as a sub-variety
of basal cell cancer. The majority of cancers
of the skin appear on the face.
Adenoid cystic carcinoma of the skin is a
form of basal cell cancer. This type is often
multiple and commonly affects the eyelids,
forehead and nose.
The lesions are first elevated, then ulcerated.
As a rule they are more radio-resistant than
the typical basal cell carcinomas.
The nose is a common site of cancer of the
skin. The majority of the basal cell type,
regional metastasis generally does not occur
until the lesion has involved the mucous membrane.
A great effort should be made to cure these
skin lesions at the first attempt, for each
recurrence presents greater difficulty. The
first therapeutic procedure, be it surgery
or irradiation, generally seals the patient's
fate.
The crucial importance of eradicating the
disease the first time can hardly be exaggerated.
Advanced lesions such as these can be avoided
only by early diagnosis and thorough treatment
when the patient first comes under observation.
Here is a basal cell carcinoma of the lower
eyelid. The lesion is early and easily curable.
A surface application of radium administered
under correct conditions results in almost
certain cure. But those must be the maximum
which the normal tissues will tolerate.
Here is a basal cell carcinoma of the nose,
which has been treated and is beginning to
undergo repair. Note that the edges of the
lesion have disappeared.
Seventy-five percent of cancers of the eyelid
are of the basal cell type. Regional lymph
node metastasis occurs in 20 percent. The
inner [inaudible] of the lower eyelid is the
most common site.
In this case a carcinoma of the left lower
eyelid has disappeared after irradiation.
But the sterilization was incomplete and several
years later an extension of the disease developed.
Adequate irradiation as a rule avoids this
complication.
Here we see one of the great tragedies of
this disease. How long did this patient wait
before consulting his physician?
Did the physician choose the best method of
treatment? How accurately and skillfully was
the treatment executed?
These are the searching questions we as physicians
must constantly keep before us. Carcinomas
of the scalp grow very slowly and almost never
invade the regional lymph nodes.
They tend to adhere to the underlying bone
and are usually first seen in their late stages.
Curable in the beginning, these lesions ultimately
destroy the bone and involve the meninges
and the brain.
Note the pulsation of the brain in this tragic
case.
And now we come to the story of what can happen
to an apparently innocent mole. There are
few tragedies in the whole realm of medicine
that equal the complications which sometimes
develop in connection with these apparently
innocent lesions.
Since the average individual harbors about
20 moles, the malignant transformation of
a mole is comparatively rare. Traumatism plays
an important role in transforming the course
of a benign nevus.
Moles, which are so located as to be subjected
to repeated trauma and moles showing clinical
signs of activity should be treated by careful
and complete surgical removal.
You have just seen a fleshy, pedunculated
mole, a type which is removed without danger.
The hairy non-segmented mole belongs to the
same category.
Pigmented macules are common and my be single
or multiple. They may be present at birth
or develop later in life. The danger of melanoma
is slight. They should be removed only on
the indications mentioned.
It is the flat bluish black or brownish black
mole that is the most dangerous of all. And
here we see a remarkable example of malignant
transformation of a bluish black mole.
Metastases to the regional lymph nodes are
already present. Microscopic examination of
a melanoma may disclose all of the cellular
features without showing the presence of pigments
or the characteristic brown intracellular
pigment may form a striking feature of the
microscopic picture as you see in this photo
microgram.
Extensive metastasis to the axillary lymph
nodes has occurred in this case following
excision of a pigmented mole on the left forearm.
Sometimes invasion remains limited to one
or two regional lymph nodes for a long time.
And it is in this group that radical dissection
has resulted in apparent cure in isolated
cases.
The scar on the left forearm indicates the
site of excision of the primary melanoma.
Melanoma may affect the scalp and metastasize
to regional lymph nodes as in this case.
Metastasis to axillary and supraclavicular
glands also occurred in this case following
traumatic treatment of a mole on the left
arm. Electrodessication is uncertain and probably
dangerous.
Careful and complete surgical excision offers
the safest course. The presence of small secondary
nodules around a melanotic tumor is an important
sign of its malignant nature.
The heel is a favorite site for melanomas.
This lesion was already accompanied by pulmonary
metastasis when first examined.
In discussing early diagnosis it is necessary
to review the steps to which a lesion passes
before it becomes malignant. In other words,
we must attempt to form a mental picture of
the nature of the cancer process.
We are now fairly certain that cancer is not
a sudden event or an accident in a previously
normal tissue, but on the contrary it is the
result of a series of changes, which may have
begun many years before.
A combination of factors seems necessary for
the initiation of abnormal growth. Hereditary
susceptibility unquestionably plays a part,
an excess or deficiency of certain hormones
and probably the presence of certain chemicals
we call carcinogenic agents combined to initiate
excessive growth of cells.
We have learned the remarkable fact that abnormal
cell growth need not necessarily result in
clinical cancer. At one extreme the growth
may be so rapid as to overwhelm the individual
in a short period of a few months.
And at the other extreme the growth may be
so slow that the patient does not live long
enough to develop clinical cancer and he dies
of other causes, harboring one or more precancerous
lesions.
Thus certain precancerous lesions require
10 years, others 20 years, still others 30
years to reach the stage of clinical cancer.
And it is well known that the older we get
the more chances we have of developing this
disease.
There is also considerable evidence to indicate
that precancerous lesions can regress and
perish in the body as a result of some defensive
mechanism, the nature of which we do not yet
understand.
And it is probable that even fully established
cancers can under certain conditions cease
to grow, regress, and even disappear.
When we use the term precancerous we generally
think of it in microscopic terms. We mean
a lesion which exhibits all the morphological
features of cancer, but which has not yet
escaped outside normal boundaries.
We must remember, however, that the morphological
appearance of a cell is a very crude index
of its biological state and even a less accurate
guide as to its future intentions.
Thus the group of neoplastic epithelial cells
confined within the normal boundaries of the
duct of the breast may be ready to invade
the lymphatics and blood vessels immediately,
or they may remain stationary for many years
or they may regress and disappear.
And yet, the microscope, as a rule, can neither
distinguish these cells nor predict their
future. Thus it is evident that cancer is
a highly complex clinical, pathological and
biological problem.
Through the medical and hospital service the
Veteran's Administration has developed over
the past 10 years an organization for the
study and treatment of cancer that is unique
in the world.
In addition to the Hines Tumor Clinic, there
are five subsidiary units in the five geographical
areas into which the country is divided, each
representing a unit organized, equipped, and
manned to offer to the veterans suffering
with cancer the latest knowledge in diagnosis
and treatment of this disease.
An elaborate system of records is maintained
and a register of tumor cases has been established,
which permits a study of resultant treatment.
In addition to highly trained full-time personnel,
all six units have consulting staff composed
of some of the leading experts in their field
whose help and advice are available when special
problems arise.
The Hines facility is not only a hospital
but is a practical governmentally controlled
training school as well. For doctors, it presents
a broad opportunity to study diseases, inviting
new methods of eliminating suffering.
For patients, the library facilities and the
many phases of properly supervised occupational
therapy such as wood carving, weaving, metal
work, recreation, etc. offer a greater incentive
to develop new channels of thinking.
Today this great facility at Hines is considered
the largest government hospital of the Veteran's
Administration, a monument which should continually
inspire us to strive to conquer this dread
disease.
It is with such institutions as this that
the helping hand of the United States government,
extended through the Veteran's Administration,
practically demonstrates its appreciation
of the spirit and loyalty of its veterans.